hey guys welcome to the Reuben report
I'm Dave Reuben I've got Cara Santa
Maria max elugu VR with me and we got a
bunch of great stories for you and this
is the Internet so we gotta move fast
here we go okay
the the Queen has almost been coronated
that's right Hillary Clinton
everything's about 2016 it seems
preordained already as bonkers is that
maybe and CNN is gonna do a documentary
about her a little bit before the
election at NBC is going to do a
miniseries about her and this has the
RNC all in their panties are in a bunch
and Rin spree abyss who is the head of
the RNC although his name sort of sounds
like a bad guy in Harry Potter he's very
upset about this and the RNC wants to
boycott the debates over this and CNN
has issued a statement instead of making
premature decisions about a project that
is in the very early stages of
development and months from completion
we would encourage the members of the
Republican National Committee to reserve
judgment until they no more should they
decide not to participate in the debates
on CNN we would find it curious as
limiting their debate participation
seems to be the ultimate disservice to
voters okay so that's CNN's statement
NBC News they said well we're not in
cahoots with NBC entertainment which I'm
not sure about that because Leno
interviewed Obama last night so I'm
pretty sure he's now the White House
chief correspondent for NBC anywho this
is a lot of buzz for Hillary Clinton
before the buzz has even begun in years
out is this stuff just so stupid and
just a culmination of everything that's
wrong with our media and the politics
yes no it's insane
what a silly bullying tactic on behalf
of the the RNC I mean it's like or are
they like preschoolers in a sandbox like
it doesn't make any sense yeah I mean I
think Reince Priebus is I don't know
whether it's legitimate or not I don't
think it's legitimate but as concerned
about you know major news organizations
coming out or appearing to come out on
the side of a particular candidate and
announce their candidacy yet and right
we have no idea who's going to be in
these debates but I I think it's it's
funny that CNN statement it had a little
snark in it yeah
and I think truth be told I mean come on
it is doing a disservice to the RNC if
they decide not to air debate on this
like large failing as it may be news
network because where else are they
gonna go are they gonna start having RNC
debates on Fox News is that the only
Avenue they're gonna be able to take now
right and that right there you can only
go to their friendly people are the
Democrats are gonna say what we're only
gonna do it on MSNBC but I sort of agree
with them in some slight thing here
because whether they're a glowing
documentary that's you know only saying
nice things about her or whether the
miniseries is all great about her or not
it seems to me that any publicity is
good publicity just builds up the
machine that is Hillary right yeah it's
like the the what are the pony show that
is politics and the 24 hour news cycle
you know it's like they sort of go hand
in hand and one fuels the fire of the
other right that if Hillary is presented
in a more critical more straightforward
and critical light that it's really
going to play into her favor I mean it
what is the alternative here is it that
they want tit for tat so like oh you
went to a miniseries about Hillary we
want a miniseries about Chris Christie
well I'm sorry but Hillary has a really
long record and she is a very
established politician and her her kind
of life it is it has contributed enough
that I think it warrants a miniseries or
a special you know in it there's there's
no reason to believe that these networks
are in cahoots with like the the DNC on
the 2016 election cycle that's crazy
so does this just go to like typical
Republican talking points which is the
media's against us so it's sort of like
they're just hopping on this to be like
see we told you the media hates us yeah
I don't know I mean it's a documentary
that I would watch you know yeah I don't
know I mean it's sad it's sad that it's
really just come down to bickering yeah
what do you say Reince Priebus is like
the worst RNC Chairman of all what what
is the deal maybe you know somebody
tweeted that if you take all the vowels
out of his name it actually goes it's
RNC PRBS I mean that's pretty
that's pretty freakin amazing they'd
like made this guy in a lab but are you
so let's talk about Hillary though in a
bigger sense like really are we just
coronating a queen is there any chance
what do you think the actual chances are
that she is not the next president I
don't know I think it's really early a
lot can happen I know I know come I can
happen in three years yeah a lot can
happen and I think the voting public is
really sickled and so if there's some
sort of big scandal that could take her
out of there I mean it could very well
happen I think it's hard to say yeah
right now I think she looks like the
best candidate but look back during the
primaries when Barack Obama ran for the
first time she was the she was the
runner at the contender there I mean she
has been in that slot for a really long
time yeah do you think that the final
part of this is just that this is just
typical like not only the political end
of it but just for the networks that
NBC's purging viewers CNN's purging
viewers so it's almost like they just
say they're gonna do this stuff because
that then just creates buzz in and of it
so the controversy is just good for the
network even right yeah it's true I mean
the world we live in you know facts are
delivered at 140 characters on Twitter
instantaneously so I think that you know
to stir up a little drama works in their
favor yeah you know and so that's just
the nature of the world we live in we
doubt that CNN our NBC even thought this
would be drama I don't think that they
decided to do this kind of programming
schedule hoping that it would ruffle the
feathers of the RNC I think that the RNC
making a big deal out of it kind of came
maybe not as a surprise but like was an
annoyance to that more than anything
right but I think it was a good point
about how who would they choose on the
Republican side to do a movie about like
are you just going to show Chris
Christie going to Golden Corral or Rand
Paul like learning from his dad in the
dark exorcisms in college so that would
be and how is that not a bigger story
but I know Bobby Jindal is like
fascinating he was gonna be he was the
golden boy they said he was gonna be
there Obama and you did that speech that
yeah
make a movie based on those exorcisms I
mean I feel like that would be more
interesting than the conjuring which got
tons I was totally bored by it totally
there was no political angle all right
let's move on I want to talk about my
favorite pot smoking left-handed gauge
you Barney Frank he was on Real Time
with Bill Maher this past Friday and he
sort of came out of the closet in a new
way okay Barney Frank do you feel more
liberated being out of Congress oh you
must
oh absolutely I don't have to worry that
when the phone rings did somebody who's
screwed something up and says it's my
responsibility to unscrew it although
you you know you were in a fairly safe
district you were not one of those
Congress people who have to worry about
every little thing you could come on
this show and sit next to a pot-smoking
atheist and it wouldn't bother you if I
which punch smoking atheist when you're
talking about
oh you are liberated oh boy I I would
tell you now I regret I had asked my
governor will point me to her yes
senator I - and I was looking forward to
having my husband Jim hold the
Constitution not the Bible and affirm
not swear that I was going to be right
wonderful senator you would have been a
wonderful set of there man do you you
and Elizabeth Warren both there that
would have been quite a team
well we can only dream alright there's
so much greatness there like talking
about rationality and sanity but what I
think is fascinating about this is
Barney Frank has been out as gay for
like 25 years or something yet couldn't
come out as an atheist until he was out
of Congress I know this is right in your
wheelhouse so I'm going to start with
you on this one is that is that the
crazy part of this that he couldn't say
this 10 years ago felt that it would
have been politically risky or whatever
well yeah I mean I I wouldn't say that
it's crazy because I think that we're so
used to this at this point but this is
what I think a lot of a theist kind of
rights groups are really pushing towards
you know I talk a lot about atheist
issues and people always ask me like why
are you trying to convert everybody or I
should say deconversion a theism is not
a religion as we know but I a you know D
program yeah but you know it's not about
that for me I don't care what religion
you are that doesn't interest me really
what it's about is is forwarding atheist
rights and we're still a group of people
who yeah can't get elected to public
office if we're out about our about our
lack of religious affiliation and so
this doesn't surprise me but it's I mean
it's good to see him come out I'm really
proud of Barney for being able to do
that he came out in a very safe space
let's be real and he came out you know
if he had done it while he was in office
I think it might have been more
impactful for the for the cause or for
the movement but I'm not going to to
denigrate him because I think that it's
great that he did it anyway and he's
already had to deal like you said with
the burden of coming out early it I mean
20 years that's a long time where he
stands with his atheism now is probably
where he did stand with his
homosexuality 20 years ago because back
then it was not easy it's still not easy
to get elected
you're an out politician yeah well
that's why I think it's just such a
great metaphor max I don't know where
you stand in jobs I mean we're good
friends and we that's one of the issues
that we both are totally in alignment I
think we need more ideas in Congress for
sure yeah I think it's great it's sad
that he has to sort of have this big you
know dramatic unveiling of his lack of a
belief system you know I think I think
more of us but is it lack of a belief
system it actually to me it shows a
belief system of a higher order actually
at least in the public sphere because by
saying well I wanted to put my hand on
the Constitution not on the Bible well
this country is run I'm pretty sure by
the Constitution or it used to be a
little bit I mean I wouldn't call that a
belief though I think that you know most
people who are public officials and want
to uphold the Constitution I think that
that's probably like the number one
platform that everybody runs on right
but I don't know I mean I get concerned
when people talk about atheism as a
belief system or as a religion because
it really is a lot you know like they
always say atheism is a religion like
bold as a hare it's not it's no religion
it's ear religion it's not like a new
Church of atheism yeah do you think that
someone like Barney Frank is going to be
given a longer leash on this now because
by being gay it's like oh well we
already think you're this like radical
left-wing
gay liberal Massachusetts do you think
that this sort of will make this easier
and it you know he's also out of the the
public eye a little bit now the guy I
mean he seems awesome like he was super
hard on that Occupy Wall Street girl on
the show yeah if you watch it he was
relentless on her I kind of felt bad for
it of what there were real parallels I
think between Real Time this Friday and
newsroom this Sunday with the Occupy
girl going on live television and even
though she newsrooms she really held her
own on real time like much more than the
character on newsroom did but uh but
yeah he was pretty tough on her when it
came to the comment she was making about
police and in lower-income neighborhoods
but aside from that I think that what
you were just asking about you know a
liberal ultra religious conservatives
lump all that in together anyway I think
they see all of those traits as being
you know traits of the devil and so I
don't think they're gonna be that
surprised
it's either they're just gonna see that
like maybe somehow the democratic
process is being taken away bit by bit
right we have atheists in office so if
it is traits of the devil I like that
now I'm guessing you two are more than
ready to vote for someone with traits of
devil do you think America is ready to
vote for someone that just says you know
what I'm an atheist or at least I'm
agnostic we don't even have someone that
even is saying that I'm agnostic I you
know make my decisions based on my own
rationality and all that yeah I mean I
like to think that America is definitely
ready you know but I obviously you know
I live in California and I've spent a
lot of time in New York one of these
pot-smoking it is the fastest-growing
minority is people who don't identify
with any particular religion I think
we're close to like 16% now which is a
really big number it's a really big
number but that includes people who are
atheist agnostic or just say you know no
comment I don't identify specifically
with any religion yeah that number
though the 16% that's that is so huge is
that a problem actually within the
Atheist community that there aren't sort
of leaders at least that I know about
that aren't pushing it in more of like a
political fashion problem that we don't
have political action committees I think
what we do but but they're not large I
think it's a problem that we don't have
lobbyists but but it's not a problem in
that we are the whole point of not
believing is that there is no organized
atheist you know we have we have
American atheist we have these different
and Dawkins and in people like that I
mean we do have these organizations
where a lot of people are getting more
involved for political action
specifically but but really it's about
having like a secular Alliance it's
about upholding the Constitution and
maintaining a separation of church and
state I think that's what's the most
important to those groups it's not about
like we said before D converting or
deprogramming anybody or bringing people
over to the Dark Age it's more about
making sure that our legislation is is
done in a secular way to kind of
preserve what the Founding Fathers
wanted when they first set out to write
the Constitution right so so here here
exactly so final thought on this because
we've talked about we've talked a lot
about atheism I sure we've talked about
a lot about pot on this show is there
some connection do you think well and is
there a little danger in the way he did
this
reveal by saying I'm a pot-smoking
atheist like this yeah I mean I think
that people that smoke tend to be more
sort of you know open-minded and free
associative and stuff like that which
might lend itself more to having
alternate spiritual beliefs or
what-have-you I don't know I mean I
think there shouldn't be a connection
deployed all right we can prove that
there's at least one knot pot smoking
atheist there you go America all right
let's move on so McDonald's have you
heard it's not good for you it really is
not this one is big and I'm completely
shocked by this story because everyone's
heard about the pink slime with
McDonald's we're gonna get into that in
just a second but just this past week
McDonald's finally announced but not
that they're changing their burger
recipe for the first time because Jamie
Oliver celebrity chef has been exposing
them for doing this horrific horrific
process with their meat where they take
the awful scraps that's left after
you've taken everything good off the cow
and then you spray it with ammonia and
there are some horrific videos about
this but we're just going to show you a
slightly cleaner one because I want you
to puke on your computer here we go the
key ingredients the process is ammonia
we're gonna wash these lean bits of beef
that we've spun around their water and
ammonia solution and that killed eco
life
and any pathogens so basically we're
taking a product that would be sold at
the cheapest fool the dopes okay so you
guys are on YouTube right now I don't
want you to click away but you can check
out some other videos that are much more
graphic than that but basically they're
taking stuff that is not fit for human
consumption
they are spraying it with a chemical
that can do all kinds of horrific things
to you then they're pumping it full of
all kinds of other stuff and food dye
all this we all know all this stuff and
now they're finally changing their
recipe because of Jamie yet the media
completely just did not pick this up
which i think is quite bizarre so my
first question is are we just destined
to eat this crap no matter what because
I almost didn't do this story because I
think everyone knows how bad McDonald's
is and even if you show them that crap
and spraying it with chemicals and that
you're getting the worst cuts of people
are still gonna go do we just want to
destroy ourself I can't even believe
that people were referring to the
original burger as a recipe it's more
formula than anything else I mean it's
the most disgusting thing I've ever seen
so I'm super psyched I think that what
Jamie has done and has been doing for a
long time is awesome and this is sort of
like I mean I think that he should
consider it a crowning achievement you
know I mean that ammonia stuff is so
gross it's I mean it's really been
killing disinfect the meat it is there
to disinfect to me you know get rid of
e.coli things like that but I have to
imagine it's also stripping it of
whatever minor nutrients might be left
in the meat is there anything I feel
like you've got something here you're
ready you know coming from a scientific
perspective I think that first and
foremost I understand the gut reaction
and and I'm not saying that I disagree
with it because I don't want to eat that
I first sure don't want to eat that so
I'm gonna come out and say that right
now but I would like to see the science
about whether or not the ammonia is
harmful to individuals about whether or
not the ammonia is rinsed away whatever
I think that in this particular case the
reason they do it now they're using
horrifically low-quality beef yeah but
that's how you get a hamburger for like
80 cents right so so the issue is yes
they have to ensure that their customers
don't get sick when they eat this now
we're talking about sick in the short
term from infection we're not talking
about aggregate sickness from eating
low-quality food that's nutritionally
barren and you know not getting the
right calories so I think that
this is less an issue about McDonald's
and the profit motive and corporate
America and bulwa and it's more an issue
of a poverty in this country I think the
real issue here is that people who live
in very very low-income neighborhoods
don't have access to healthy clean food
and they're left with only you know a
handful of options which is eating
basically McDonald's dog food on a bun
and yeah I think it's easy for us in
like the [ __ ] top 5% or whatever to
sit around and say like oh you know we
Angelenos would never want to sit around
and there's you know there's hardly any
even fast-food restaurants in Los
Angeles we're very lucky in that respect
but go to certain neighborhoods even
here go to South Central go to Compton
and see what kinds of food choices
people have available to them that's the
problem and that's what we should be
trying to solve I mean I you know I
somewhat agree but I also think that
like where there's a supermarket um
there are healthy options and it's just
it's a matter of Education I actually
I've been hanging out recently with um
Adrian Grenier who has a company called
shift and he actually just released a
new app called food tripping which helps
anybody anywhere in the world find local
organic sustainable healthy food options
a matter where you are but I would I
would venture to guess that the number
of little pins on this app are
significantly higher in rich
neighborhoods right I also think that
when you're talking about
a single mother who's working three jobs
and doesn't have time to go to the
supermarket and buy fresh ingredients
and go home and cook a nice meal for her
family
you know she has five minutes to figure
out how to feed her family on a budget
of like three dollars a person what do
you do but get a big bucket of chicken
from KFC I mean the whole system in this
country is I don't want to say design
because that makes it sound like there's
some sort of vast conspiracy but over
time has been has been manipulated in
such a way to keep impoverished people
in a position where they can't grow out
of that poverty and I think a big part
of doing that is being able to eat well
and being able to think clearly when you
go to school when you go to work I mean
it's there's such a link there and then
those poor people of course have either
Oh healthcare or worse healthcare and
they're getting sicker and then they're
you know getting less medical help or no
medical help sometimes some people don't
even realize that like fruit juice is
unhealthy you know and stuff like that
no and and these are all kind of
correlating variables when you go to
low-income areas that's the sad thing is
that the the the school systems are bad
the individuals don't have you know
appropriate education available to them
they don't have proper nutrition
available to them and it's just you know
a kind of spiraling problem we have all
known about this pink slime thing and
we've because they just announced that
they'd switch the recipe but apparently
they did it a few months ago but we've
all known about this and I'm sure that
well I can't swear that we're all gonna
go back to McDonald's but at some point
you might be somewhere on the road and
have to stop somewhere so we know like
even now we were talking about this
earlier but in an out burger here in
California you know it's not cows eating
other cows and all that but it's cheap
but it's just as cheap as McDonald's and
yet for some reason people still go to
McDonald's so I don't know that it's
always about the choices people are
people want to destroy themselves in a
weird way I think yeah I mean I think
it's where we're educated enough in Los
Angeles to know that in and out is
relatively natural in comparison to
McDonald's and that's why a lot of
people choose in and out and even when
you're at the in-and-out drive-through
you can then make the choice whether or
not you're gonna have your burger
protein style or with the white bleached
and rich flour by want to show you guys
a picture of the pink slime in case you
haven't seen the pink slime I mean think
about that really just try to get that
in your brain and go 13 percent of my
mcdonald's burger until they just
changed this recipe or formula as you
aptly called it is that yeah I mean I
can't I honestly can't remember the last
time that I ate at McDonald's and I
think that there's some other great
things about you in and out you know
can't sing their praises enough and I
know that they have like Bible verses on
their bags or whatever kind of annoying
I know it's it's annoying
but um but they they win as an atheist
you finally find a burger you're by the
bike their workers treatment their - you
know it's not just about higher-quality
food they you know offer their their
employees full benefits
offer them the starting wage is higher
than the statewide minimum wage they
even have great programs for their
workers like they can leave their
uniforms at work and they'll be
laundered for them so they don't have to
take that fast-food smell home with them
so they're not kind of walking around
yeah I mean it's a really I think kind
of forward-looking company and so yes I
guess I kind of do retract my earlier
statement about about this isn't really
about corporate America and about profit
motive and things like that because it
would be interesting to kind of compare
the business model of McDonald's in and
out again we're talking though about a
multinational corporation versus
something that's kind of just only on
the west coast now know what you know
you're having a good conversation when
one of the panelists retracts and
earlier that means something was
happening here that we were actually
having a conversation all right Larry
there you go all right let's talk about
Twitter a new study by Nielsen shows
that tweeting and watching television
actually does correlate to ratings which
I'm going to refer to this for now on as
the sharknado principle so this is you
know the Nielsen ratings in my opinion
basically have just been this made-up
thing that we've all sort of accepted
and that's not really just my opinion a
lot of people have written about that
it's just this made-up thing and there's
a box on somebody's TV somewhere in 1960
and we're still paying attention to it I
think this is really cool and I think
this is sort of the future of media and
the type of stuff we're doing around
here this social experience that we're
all having while watching TV and
something like sharknado I think is the
perfect example of this nobody heard of
it until about two hours before it was
on Syfy network suddenly it somehow got
some traction on Twitter and then I
spent two hours not only watching it but
having this experience on Twitter
playing along with everyone joking about
how horrific and stupid it was and and
it was kind of great and it gets the
buzz going so you're you're doing a new
show take part where you guys are doing
a lot of your tweeting the entire time
basically in Burien during during
commercial breaks and you're tweeting on
air
last week and you're tweeting while we
were talking how important is the the
social media component to television and
all the other forms of me I think that
you know I think that we're seeing kind
of an evolution in TV viewing especially
in young people I think that people are
still watching cable news or cable
television I think that there is still
some amount of appointment television
but for the most part people are DVR and
things and a lot of people have moved
off to the cable pay model and they've
moved on to kind of a Hulu Netflix model
and I think that this kind of community
engagement is a way that the cable
companies can really tap in to their
dying fan base and bring them back
because if the entire globe or I should
say all of America at least is coming
together to watch a you know a program
live and it's it's more compelling it's
more fun if they're there right when it
airs because they can all communicate
like we saw with sharknado I think that
more people are going to tune in in that
way I also see I don't want to say a
downside of that specifically but if you
watch take part live last night actor
I'm not sure if it was last night at
that night be I think it was a night
before a Monday night we part of the
decoder segment I talked a lot about
Shark Week and about discovery and how
they opened up Shark Week with a
documentary about C Megalodon kind of
claiming that that it's probably still
alive it hasn't yet gone extinct and and
you know I obviously had a room which is
this huge crazy shark right yeah it's a
big shark that was extinct between 1.5
and 2 million years ago so III have a
real problem with it's very similar to
what they did on Animal Planet and again
this is discovery communications it's
all the same conglomerate Animal Planet
aired a documentary a while back about
mermaids and how they're still alive and
people thought it and people thought it
was real and a lot of people thought
that this C Megalodon documentary is
real and they've kind of defended their
stance saying that they want to feed
into the fantasy and blah blah blah
there was like one very short disclaimer
and to me this does a huge disservice to
science communication in this country
and I think I spent all this time being
very high and mighty and kind of blaming
discovery and blaming discovery and I
didn't take a moment to look at the
ratings and who's watching and think
maybe I should be kind of taking some of
the blame upon ourselves like we
want I say we I don't I didn't you know
but but many people want this kind of
programming and a lot of times even with
this link to Twitter these companies
these media companies are feeding in to
what the people are asking for anyway
now I think that's a horrible horrible
mistake if you are delivering news or
nonfiction programming but across the
board when it comes to fiction
programming I think what we're seeing is
the like idiocracy
just like my judge movie of America it's
really dangerous such a good yeah as
long as it in a you know rear sharknado
during Shark Week in NATO is already
getting a sequel but what isn't there
something cool about that experience in
and of itself even if it doesn't really
translate so it's two ratings because I
don't know that the ratings actually of
sharknado were that those were not as
record-setting as the like they were
still beating out I think like primetime
shows on major networks which you would
never expect happen on sci-fi right so
it helps but it but that experience
that's the part that I think is really
cool like whether it is amazing yeah
it's like the same power that can like
liberate you know authoritarian
governments you know in the Middle East
like a network you know 10 years ago the
best they could hope for is like some
press and water core conversation but
today the water cooler is global and
it's on Twitter you know isn't it it's
an amazing world we live in our whole
like shared collective experience of
something is like changed yeah so that
means does it even matter if people are
watching because that's the part that I
think is interesting here Nielsen seems
to be sort of made up and maybe we're
gonna get to a point where it doesn't
even matter what people it's just what
they're talking about not what they're
like well I was I was like seeing all of
the chatter I was in Vegas for a
conference of seeing all the chef's
granted I was tweeting like I'm so
bummed that I'm not wearing sharknado I
can't believe what everybody's saying
just happened to I ins earring and you
know so but I still haven't seen it
that's funny we're here in California so
we I was you know it's all happening
during the East Coast feed so I was
actually just tweeting the tweeting of
sharknado I wasn't even tweeting sorry
there's not a simultaneous 28 on a lot
of these networks so final thought on
this when you go to the old-school
programming like CNN is now bringing
back crossfire which we've talked about
which i think is the absolute worst TV
show in a history of television and I
just saw that they launched their
Twitter account you know it's got a
couple hundred followers is there
something about like the old-school
media companies and they're sort of
inability to really handle the social
media stuff the way that a younger thing
like take part of what we do here can
really do it because it's true it's not
coming from some like corporate I mean I
don't think that Twitter buzz is enough
to to fund good content you know at the
end of the day and so I think that like
people still need to tune in and support
the shows that they that they like to
watch because it's sort of like the
Conan O'Brien effect - it's like when
Conan was having that whole thing with
the Tonight Show and he had like
obviously a way bigger support base and
then Jay Leno but his support base
they're not watching TV you know so like
I think he was that's why that's part of
the reason why he was relegated so I
don't know I mean I think that right now
you know content will get made and
Twitter buzz is sort of enough to
support that but yeah the ad model is
going to need to sort of catch up do you
think it's kind of a finding right good
statistics to show what everybody kind
of already thought but yeah yeah yeah
the more people that are talking about
on Twitter probably the more people are
watching there you go you crazy
youtubers Twitter is good okay very good
let's talk about Education for a little
bit I like to think you learn a little
something on this show maybe you get a
little dumber it could be I'm not sure
if it's a net gain or a net loss each
week but the Wall Street Journal has
done a report that a teacher in South
Korea is making four million dollars a
year now that would make you think that
they put a different emphasis on
education than we do here in the United
States
Kim Ki hoon has been teaching for over
20 years and he does these private ask
after school tutoring programs and he is
paid accordingly because he does a
really good job let's take a look at
some some facts about education
this is South Korea versus the United
States high school graduation rate in
the u.s. 77 percent
Korea 93% eighth graders ranked advanced
it's 7% in the u.s. 47% in South Korea
and in 2012 the u.s. spent 15 billion on
video games
South Korea spent 17 billion on tutoring
services all right I mean it's hard to
argue with numbers like that so there's
a lot of ways we can go here but first
off do we just not put the right
emphasis on education in any way
whatsoever yeah I think I think
education is definitely like ripe for
disruption and it makes me really happy
to hear that an educator is being
appreciated you know in that way in
South Korea but on the other hand you
know the fact that there are so many
problems with education here in the US
has given rise to really innovative
startups like Khan Academy and the
amazing things that they're doing in
education or a platform for a guy like
Ken Robinson to have the most viewed TED
talk of all time you know and his
thoughts on how education needs to be
like disrupted so um so yeah I mean I
think there's a lot of exciting things
going on in this country but yes to
answer your question is basically do you
think it's ever possible that we will
pay our educators like this guy I mean
this guy's basically being paid like a
basketball player or a professional
athlete I mean I think that's I think
it's really cool but I think it does
open up to kind of a devil's advocate
discussion too which is about this gang
gets paid really well because he does
private after-school tutoring and only
rich people are able to buy seats in his
lecture halls only rich people are able
to buy individual downloads of his
lectures so I think that this model
although yes I would love to see
teachers actually getting bonuses and
teachers being paid more for doing a
good job and not just like a static
salary where we're all teachers
performance is put into one pot and it
doesn't really kind of entice teachers
to do a better job because let's be real
that is the one variable in the
classroom that actually matters across
almost everything else having a really
solid good teacher who's invested in who
cares is going to have the biggest
impact on the education of the students
but at the same time a model like this
could potentially just increase the rift
between the upper and the lower classes
in this country and we already have a
huge middle class problem yes
I could see this going either way it's a
good point like either the rich people
are just going to keep being able to pay
better teachers or because everything
the more it goes online and the more
people that get involved it's sort of
like health care that the hope is you
get more people in on it and there's
more resources and then it ultimately
gets cheaper but I guess people you know
this individual made news because he is
the most sought-after teacher in South
Korea that's why he's making four
million dollars but these are highly
competitive tutoring programs and so
there are a lot of people vying for
those spots there are a lot of people
vying to make that much money so the
hope would be that even individuals who
maybe aren't as successful as this
individual teacher are able to pull in
you know a specific amount of money and
for individuals might be able to put
their students into those after-school
programs but it really looks like it's
an issue of priorities the parents are
prioritizing different in that country
they're willing to put money into their
children's education over putting money
into you know maybe whatever we're
wasting our money on here right but is
there any I oh I'm a big video game guy
I used to work at Electronics Boutique I
don't want to brag system manager you
know but is there any risk in an
overemphasis I don't want to just focus
on that like is there any risk in an
overemphasis on education and that maybe
we are getting something here in the
United States because our kids do play a
lot and play video games about what are
they I don't know what the kids I mean
recess is getting cut a lot of kids
aren't you know parents are too scared
to let their kids play outside we have
like a massive childhood obesity
epidemic in this country yeah obviously
I think that we need to have a
well-rounded approach to education and I
think there's obviously a risk of being
too kind of totalitarian with the way
that you raise your children and forcing
education on them to an extent that you
don't like get enough hours of sleep at
night or that you don't get to exercise
so if we found out that South Koreans
were much smarter than us and even more
productive but at the end of the day
we're not as happy because we don't I'm
just playing devil's advocate here for a
second but not as happy because we do
play whether it's outside or just
sitting on PlayStation do you think it's
it's a worth trade-off it's a worthy
trade-off
verse happiness halogens um no I think
that I think intelligence is definitely
or fee not it's not even intelligence
per se because there's no way to even
standardize you know like one sort of
overarching intelligence quotient
obviously but we should do our best to
provoke imagination amongst children and
sort of creative output and and you know
Malcolm clout Gladwell calls it
concerted cultivation you know putting
kids and as many sort of creative novel
environments as possible I think putting
too much emphasis on STEM education
could be problematic and that's sort of
like Ken Robinson's whole thing is that
we should be doing more to get children
to think creatively and being a conflict
between thinking creatively and having
an emphasis on STEM education I think we
should be changing the way that we
approach their education so that
creative thought is a part of STEM
education you think they're they're
exactly equal do you think that we
should be teaching them completely
equally like sort of the facts and then
how to use the brain I think that doing
science is ultimately using the creative
part of your brain you cannot be a
successful scientist without being a
very creative out-of-the-box thinker and
I think what a lot of people draw the
analogy that science is math and so you
have to be great a minute I can be good
at science you know like it's a very
sort of it's a creative endeavor I think
that if we start students understanding
math theory and not just memorizing
times tables I think that there's a
better approach there too that's a
totally different well you know it
reminds me of you know how Albert
Einstein who you know our greatest
scientist ever you know couldn't tie his
shoes you know like he could probably
but the fact that he had trouble doing
sort of daily simple tasks and because
his brain was operating in a whole other
realm that a few of us ever get to yeah
although if you smoke some of that pot
that we talked about earlier in the show
I guess there's a chance okay we went
all over the place with that one okay
all right one more for ya pour and we
can't do a week here without pouring
there's just porn news constantly Big
Time porn star Jenna Presley her real
name's Brittany Ruiz which they tell me
she's one of the biggest female porn
stars around I'm not quite sure from my
own research
she has left the sex industry and of
who's she thanking of course Jesus let's
take a look so I got involved with the
adult industry when I was in college in
Santa Barbara I began dancing and from
that point forward a couple producers
came in and they said that I was
beautiful and that I would be great in
romance movies so in chale the next day
and I shot my very first scene and I
felt soul loves that day because I was
put in here and makeup I was told I was
beautiful I was gonna be a star and they
sent my pictures over to an adult agency
who I was with for about two years and
the rest is pretty much history I guess
you could say I don't think I've ever
heard porn being referred to as romance
movies to get you into porn it just
seems like it was a ploy right like
you'd be wonderful in romance yeah
there's nothing romantic about a
gangbang I assure you of that
all right so I don't want to be totally
glib about this because she also talks
about how getting out of the business
and got her out of drugs and all the
other bad things that we all know are
associated with porn so not being
totally glib but we're gonna be a little
good because it is porn what what is it
about religion that everyone that gets
out of porn they it's always because of
religion no one seems to be able to do
it just sort of on their own volition or
their own intellect or I don't think
that's true I think that probably
happens all the time I just don't think
it makes a do about it yeah I mean I
think that this is a good public
interest story it's fine I don't care
why she did it I mean because ultimately
whether it's about Jesus or whatever I
really think it comes down to the woman
right there was like a pastor there's
somebody who's involved with this church
who focuses and targets
sex workers people in the sex industry
and helps them get out of the lifestyle
that could be detrimental to them and
I'm not saying that all people in the
sex industry
need to be saved I think there are a lot
of very kind of independent sex workers
who take their job very seriously if
they don't get into drugs and alcohol
and they don't have any problems outside
of that but there are individuals who do
make bad decisions and there are plenty
of people who have made huge amounts of
money that are living clean lives that
are married and you know otherwise okay
so this website
xxx church.com I went to the site it
looks it's a really cool website like
they got a good hip web designer and it
looks cool and there's a community of
people on there is this like the next
step for the church that they're gonna
really sort of step up this kind of you
know feel looks cool kind of stuff to
get people away from porn because
they're still hung up on porn yeah which
is why we talk about it it's a it's a
fine line I mean the last thing I want
to see is a camp a Christian campaign
you know that goes against the porn
industry
um the porn industry definitely has
problems I I personally I'm totally
happy for her that she found religion
and decided to get out of the energy
because she says that the reason why she
got it into it to begin with was because
she didn't feel any love throughout her
life and you know the church provided
the McDonald's version of love to her
and and and it works for her I actually
met a porn star once and I actually I
actually talked her out of the industry
like I I met her and we became friends
and she I think would credit me as as
like helping her get out of it because
she's a really smart woman and came from
a very similar background yeah I think
she had like it's crazy she had like a
master's degree and that was part of the
marketing that the porn industry was
using here's like this really smart
woman who was like doing porn and I she
was a really big well-known porn company
and it's just sad you know like it's
it's a it's sad to see women get sucked
into it for those kinds of reasons yeah
I mean it's not when it's not an
independent decision that they're making
when it's when it's because they're
down-and-out and this is a way to make
some quick easy cash but again I don't
want to isn't that good like we
naturally think that that's bad but it's
like you know there are strippers that
put themselves through college sure if
they don't have any moral opposition to
it but obviously she felt like her
lifestyle was kind of
running out of control and she didn't
she wasn't able to to handle the
lifestyle that she was living anymore so
I think a lot of it kind of comes down
to their own personal perception whether
or not they feel like strong and in
control of their own lives or whether
they feel like they got sucked into a
particular industry but I think that you
know first of all this whole like xxx
church and is this the new this is not
new like was it do Jesus like take Mary
Magdalene or like this is not a new
concept right religious people who are
like helping the poor and the sex
workers and whatever yeah this is I I
don't I don't really understand why this
is news right because I think that it's
like well yeah that's what you're
supposed to do isn't that like supposed
to be in your mission and as a New
Testament Christian but isn't there
something a little weird psychologically
they call it xxx Church it sounds sort
of dirty and poor knee right there so
it's almost like there's a [ __ ] I know I
get it's the initiative but there's
still something about it that sounds a
little dirty like they're still trying
to wrangle you in a sound like they're
like nun porn in the back yeah like in
the rectory I think we wrapped it up on
rectory I think that was sort of the
first what you can't file a rectory with
much more all right I want to thank Cara
Santa Maria and max Lugo here and there
on the Twitter believe it or not there
are handles are right below yeah and oh
subscribe there is a button it's right
you cannot miss it and if you're color
blind if there's a little gray box is it
gray if you're colorblind would you see
red as gray you don't really see it as
gray you just can't tell the difference
between red and green there's a box just
click it thanks for watching we'll do
this again next week